hello and welcome to this video insists
the white game against YK y que Julia
turkey so what is he going to play twins
gambit so playing one of the sideline
today sometimes employed I mean I can
take what the Queen a g6 this is not not
particularly good but you have to play
Knight c3 first this is now again okay
fun okay let's let's just see what
happens maybe it doesn't matter all that
much in the end okay so what do we have
call them not much we should be seven
was probably a good move for some
trickery 94 and I would not look yet we
get a threat yeah I can take but it's
probably really absolutely nothing so
let's put it back
yeah i'm not i'm not that not that
unsatisfied with this I think white has
a small eggshell camera doesn't really
help yeah I've got chances here for
slight edge in the ending let's see who
I don't want to trade I can trade and
Jack put the King on dear form of course
he should lose but this is the right
position against her yeah the junior
player the saw this already looks like
that looks in precise already in the
setup let's see I mean okay
and yeah okay G for a bit to play g4 so
also g5 I'm not unhappy to play okay
this is an interesting question now if I
should take with the f porn or with the
H porn I think f porn is interesting h5
is an interesting idea here to at the
end get to the f7 pawn kids gain a bit
more space
I'm not sure I want to put this on a
file but i think i will now i think it
was wow really wow let you can survive
that's hard to believe okay so he's 5 or
not who or taking it's not so easy the
same
[Music]
and I want to play five your take hmm so
to believe I'm getting
[Music]
can't wait five year just just keeping
more stuff on the board
[Music]
so don't really have a triangulation
join 18 have a triangulation somewhere
in the speaking and porn ending like
today there are two things
[Music]
I it's just you cannot win it
unfortunately there are offered I
totally hate to do it game on now maybe
I just take on the fibers it can be a
draw I mean the five looks absolutely
atrocious but it might be a draw because
it's too close right beam can maybe it's
not enough maybe it's just not enough
okay check you really i mean this is
this is really trying to do that I mean
but maybe it's just really not enough
okay the engine things h5 and then like
f4 bit interesting 9f for weegy form
then everyone and that seems very good
yeah yeah I was looking more for dark
squared set up Frankie this also looks
good but might not win since the thing
[Music]
they probably is a droid two closer I
have no way to to train delay them or
anything like in this position if you
like going back maybe like you here and
then he does this and I go here this is
I cannot triangle later if I get quindi
kinky for this position I win but he's
not allowing that yeah he can skin is
another movie I just on kinky for a
single King c6 and i cannot i cannot i
cannot go around here and maybe I should
have tried that actually something like
that which is just exactly in time to
stop everything okay tada thanks for
watching